[موسيقى]
المانيا تطارد جاسوس بوتين في السماء
يعلنوا تحدي الدب الروسي وبيض يقلب طاوله
الحرب ويظهر منه وسط بشكل مفاجئ
الحل الوحيد هو ان تضمون اليكم بينما تدعو
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه الى سرعه اخلاء بخموت
فما الذي يجري وزير الاسرائيلي في موقف
مرعب والسبب روسيا الجيش الروسي يغير جلده
مجددا وفرنسا تعلنها لن نقف في وجه موسكو
واشنطن تغضب الصين ترد بتصريح شديد اللهجه
وتايوان تستقبل وفدا صينيا فهل حان وقت
السلام بعيدا عن الامريكان صافرات الانذار
تدوي في اليابان والسبب ومجموعه سبع ترد
وايران تعلن عن حفله الانتقام واول
ضحاياها سفينه اسرائيليه وبعد ان اشعر
اصابه بوتين بمرض خبيث ها هو بيض يظهر في
غرفه العمليات لسبب ذاته
[موسيقى]
روسيا تتقدم والغرب يتالم
الروس الدار قوتهم والاوكران يعانون من
كثافه الهجمات الروسيه مع التقدم للجيش
الروسي يقابله تراجع لقواتك ومع اقتراب
الذكرى السنويه الاولى لبدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا تبدو روسيا اقرب من اي وقت مضى
لتحقيق احد اهم اهدافها نعم مدينه بخموت
على وشك السقوط في احضان موسكو لتدعو
اوكرانيا سكان بخموت لاخلائها فورا مع
اشتداد القتال حول المدينه اليكم المصدر
مؤشرات السقوط المحتمل للمدينه جاءت من
الجانب الاوكراني بدعوه سكانها الى
اخلائها فورا الدعوه اطلقتها نائبه رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني صافرات الانذار تنطلق
فجاه لترعب وزير خارجيه الكيان الاسرائيلي
خلال زياره ملكياب في اول زياره رسميه معل
[موسيقى]
بينما كان الغرب يتفاوض بشان ارسال
الدبابات كان الكرملين يفكر في سبل خنق
مولدوفا اول المستجيبين له كان رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني في سوناك الذي اعلن ان
بلاده ستمد اوكرانيا بمعدات عسكريه تتجاوز
قيمتها امدادات العام الماضي وتقدر
بمليارين و300 جنيه خلال العام الجاري
ليعلن التحدي الروس بالتاكيده ان بريطانيا
ستكون اول دوله تمد اوكرانيا باسلحه بعيده
المدى حتى تتمكن من تحقيق النصر على روسيا
ونوه سوناك بان بريطانيا ستساعد ايه دوله
تريد امداد اوكرانيا بطائرات اذا فلما لا
تمدها انت بالطائرات يا حفيد غاندي ليجيب
وزير الدفاع البريطاني
يقولا للعلم ان التزويد اوكرانيا
بالمقاتلات بعيد المنال ذلك بحسب صحيفه
اليكم المصدر الى تطورات الوضع في
اوكرانيا حيث قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني
بن واليس ان تزويد اوكرانيا بالمقاتلات
بعيد المنال وهي فرنسات تنضم لبريطانيا
وذلك برفض ارسال دبابات قتال رئيسيه الى
اوكرانيا او اي اسلحه هجوميه يمكن
استخدامها في مهاجمه الاراضي الروسيه
الدور على سيده التصريحات اللامعه الخال
فرنسا فرع روسيا نعم لقد عرفتموها انها
ماريا زخرفه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه حيث اتهمت الولايات المتحده
بتحريض اوكرانيا على تصعيد الحرب بدعم
الهجمات على شبه جزيره القرد محذره من ان
دعاه الحرب اي الامريكيين يتورطون الان
بشكل مباشر في الصراط لان المجانين يحلمون
بهزيمه موسكو وفق كان هذا التصريح ردا على
اللي ما تتسمى فيكتوريا مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون السياسيه والتي
قالت ان بلادها ترى ان القرمه التي ضمت
روسيا من اوكرانيا في 2014 يجب ان تكون
منزوعه السلاح على الاقل وان واشنطن تدعم
الهجمات الاوكرانيه على اهداف عسكريه في
شبه الجزيره اما ريجيسوناك فعد ليقول ان
انخفاض مخزونات اسلحه دول الغرب ليس امرا
سلبيا مضيفا ان ما يتم ارساله الى
مهمته الرئيسيه في اضعاف القوات الروسيه
وتعزيز امن الغربيين لننتقل الى معارك
الالماني في السماء لمطارده جاسوس روسي
وبعد ان كانت الاستخبارات الالمانيه قد
اشتبهت باختراق جهازها لتاتي المساعده من
الاف بي اي الذي لحق الجاسوس وهو مسؤول
كبير في الاستخبارات بالمانيا
وعلى متن طائره تم القبض عليه في يناير
الماضي بحسب واشنطن بوست لتتوالى بعدها
عمليات توقيف عملاء اخرين في هولندا
ونرويج
والنمسا وبولندا
ومع كل هذه الاخبار تعمل وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه على تغيير جلدها باجراء تغييرات
في قيادتها في مختلف المناطق العسكريه من
دون توضيح اسباب هذه التغييرات فما هو
الجديد يا هؤلاء معارك الصيني وامريكا
تقرع طبونها الحرب البارده تقترب من
نهايتها بين الصين وامريكا لكن ليس لتنتهي
المعارك بينهما وانما لتنطلق حرب من نوع
اخر وما بعد ازمه المناطيد ليس كما قبلها
وهنا خرج بيض قائلا انه لا توجد مؤشرات
على ان الاجسام الطائره
ببرنامج تجسس للصين مشيرا الى فرديه
ارتباط هذه الاجسام الطائره بشركات خاصه
او مؤسسه بحثيه وماذا عن المنطاد يا هذا
تجيب الخارجيه الصينيه ان واشنطن انتاكت
الاعراف الدوليه باسقاطها المنطاد حيث وجه
وزير الخارجيه الصيني
حديثه الى واشنطن بلهجه شديده مستنكر رد
فعلها الهستيري على تحليق من طرد صيني
اسقطته بطائره مقاتله متسائلا عن كل هذه
الاجراءات الحمائيه يقول السماء مليئه
بالمناطيد من دول مختلفه هل تريدون اسقاط
كل منها هذا لا يبرهن ان امريكا قويه
لتتجه بكين نحو تايوان حيث افادت وكاله
الانباء المركزيه بجزيره تايوان وفدا
حكوميا صينيا وصل الى تايوان لاول مره منذ
ثلاثه اعوام من اجل المشاركه في مهرجان
الفوانيس فيما تتحدث تقارير غربيه عن
محادثات سريه بين
واشنطن الاسبوع المقبل
الاحداث والتطورات
اطلقت كوريا الشماليه صاروخا بالستيا
عابرا للقارات ليسقط في المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخاصه باليابان حسب ما اعلن
طوكيو وذلك سباقا لمناورات عسكريه امريكيه
كوريه جنوبيه الاسبوع المقبل في واشنطن
بحسب وكاله
لتردد دول مجموعه السبع بالسلوك غير
المسؤول لكوريا الشماليه بعد هذا الاطلاق
للصاروخ البالستي تعرضت سفينه واحده على
الاقل تملكها اسرائيل لهجوم في بحر العرب
في العاشر من فبراير الجاري بهجوم يفترض
ان ايران نفذته وفق روترد كشف تقرير حديث
صادر عن طبيب الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
انه يعاني من ثلاثه امراض بينما ازيل ورم
جلدي من صدره وسيتم اخضاعه لفحص مخبري
للتحقق مما اذا كان حميدا او خبيثا نعم
واشنطن كانت تتمنى ان يكون هذا المرض في
جسد بوتين فيا لا عداله الاقدار ليظهر في
جسد رئيسها روسيا تضرب والغربيون يجتمعون
بعد كل ضربه فما الذي سيخرجون به بعد
اجتماعهم الاخير هذا